this is book notes c-span 60-minute
discussion with the authors of public
policy historical and political works
for the next hour you'll see behind the
titles and gain insight into the authors
as people and the experiences which
shape their lives
this week our guest is andrew nagorski
warsaw bureau chief for newsweek
magazine
he joins us to discuss his recent book
the birth of freedom
shaping lives and societies in the new
eastern europe
[Music]
andrew nagorski author of the birth of
freedom if someone buys this book what
do they get
well what i hope they get is a look at
what's happened to countries like poland
hungary and czechoslovakia and to the
people in those countries since those
remarkable developments in 1989 when
they were in the headlines when these
people were were bringing down the old
system and since then i think a lot of
people in america and other countries
have sort of lost track and said well
what's going on with these people and
how once when all the rules are changed
when everything absolutely changes in
your life and and the possibilities are
suddenly totally different than they
were before what happens to individual
lives what happens to political
institutions what happens to the economy
and through the stories of individuals
i've known before communism fell
and how they've transformed their lives
since then i try to try to give an
answer to those questions you married a
polish woman that's right i was an
exchange student in in poland in my
senior year in college in 1968 69 uh for
a semester and uh it was a busy semester
because at the end of it i i ended up
married and uh
and uh so that of course has
uh affected my interest in the region my
own parents came from poland originally
so so there always was that interest i
grew up speaking polish at home uh so
that was all the more reason
why i really wanted to be able to tell
the next chapter in this story how many
kids do you have four kids uh where do
you live now we live in warsaw
once
i had been based in
bonn for
newsweek in the mid 80s and traveled all
around eastern europe then
and then in the late 80s i came back to
washington for two years
and
once everything started opening wide
open
opening up in poland and in the other
countries
i asked to be based in warsaw so that i
could cover the region on a permanent
basis not simply flying in and out we
were looking at this cover uh who is the
young man there with the flag and what
flag is it
it's it's a sort of a generic flag as
best a a generic individual as far as i
can tell it's then
this person is not identified i think it
may actually be a young woman
uh it's it's it's hard hard to tell i
suspect the flag is the this is the flag
of czechoslovakia uh but uh it's it's
done in such a way that it's meant to
represent the changes in the region the
the revolutions in the region but not
one particular country
where were you born
i was born in scotland uh it's it's a
rather
uh
it's because of the fate of my parents
they were in poland at the start of
world war ii
my father fought against the germans in
in in 1939 after poland surrendered
they our polish officers were supposed
to
to surrender as well he escaped
eventually making it to france and after
france fell
getting to britain he fought with the
polish forces under british command and
after the war
they decided to go back and go to the
states instead of back to poland where
because of the communist regime and i
delayed their departure somewhat
where did you grow up in the united
states
i grew up
a bit in new york and then a bit in
washington and then my father joined the
american foreign service when i was
at 12 years old so from then on i
started bouncing around the world
as the son of a american diplomat the
way i've bounced my own children around
the world as as a journalist what do
your kids think of living in warsaw
they've enjoyed it very much
my two oldest daughters are already
once one just finished college and one
is in college and then i have two
younger boys
so so the two older daughters have just
been commuting in and out they've been
in and out on vacations and they've been
uh one daughter spent a semester as an
exchange student as well
uh
but uh what what's been fun in poland is
that
for these in the three years we've been
there you see the remarkable changes and
it affects everything from the fact that
my 13 year old son can now go out and
and and uh
and and and not only go to mcdonald's
and taco bell and and and uh and and do
the sort of things american 13 year olds
like to do
but just uh
you see how how uh
how much much
more vitality and energy there is in
that system and when people's
uh when the when the when the breaks
have been taken off on people's uh
ability to
to to go out and do things for
themselves when those limits which were
there are removed
you uh quote somebody
in your book is saying that they used to
count the number of them
of uh western cars against the trobons
to know uh you know how well the country
was doing and said now they count the
number of trabants
against the western cars the opposite
way how many trombones are they and what
are what is the troban how many are they
in in poland now
they're the trabant is the infamous east
german car which is made out of not even
out of metal but some sort of composite
plastic and it's a small two-cylinder
car that produces more pollution than
the largest american car you can imagine
it's it's one of the great achievements
of of the old systems technology
but it was cheap and that was what what
people
and drove
now that's that's seen as as a car that
nobody who who can aspire to anything
higher would want to be seen driven
driving it of course there are some left
uh but but for the most part right now
you see very few of them uh sometimes
you have
you have a problem in poland in that
east germans who all so many of them had
turbans
now to get rid of them in the new era as
they all want to move up to west german
cars sometimes they cross the border
into poland and just ditch the car
because to avoid the rather high fee the
junkyards in germany take for these
turbines
what what is different in warsaw besides
the mcdonald's
for you
and
in the context of that question tell us
how many years overall you have lived in
warsaw well i have actually lived in
warsaw only these three but i uh i spent
that semester before as an exchange
student and then i was in in krakow in
southern poland and then i i used to go
in and out of poland quite a bit both
privately to visit visit my wife's
family and and some relatives i have
there and then as a journalist
uh what's different uh aside from just
the range of choices which the
beginnings of a consumer society
produces
what i found most different and
startling was instead of coming into a
society where there was a a a
government in power that was essentially
at war war with its people and and
trying to suppress
every popular impulse you now have the
people who i knew in the old days as
dissonance
who were who were in prison who were
fighting their running battles those
were the people who took power
and so for me as a journalist to
suddenly find people who i who are poets
or philosophers or are our are banned
writers
suddenly becoming prime ministers
presidents members of parliament editor
editors of the maine newspapers to see
that transformation that was the most
startling difference
and of course having known these people
in the in the old days
now when
when they're
when they were really looking for
contacts with the western press
uh it's it's been a pleasure to be able
to deal with them in a new situation you
have a kind of access and that goes goes
with having known them for a long time
you picked uh poland czechoslovakia or
the czech republic actually you also
wrote about slovakia and um hungary
hungary how come no east germany
i felt that if you wanted to look at
what's what this transformation means
then those three countries you mentioned
are the most logical
because uh east germany is a very
special case it's a country that
did not so much liberate itself as it
was simply reintegrated into germany
with all the problems that has entailed
but it's it's a it it had that big
brother west germany to
to try to deal with its problems one can
talk about whether it has dealt with
that problems and i'd argue that in some
ways east germans are in a more
difficult situation than the polls and
czechs and the hungarians even though
there's they've got a lot more money
flowing in there
but uh they
but but i felt the east german situation
was so peculiar
that i couldn't really make make
comparisons uh on a systematic way
while in in between the polish and the
situation the situation czechoslovakia
in hungary you could because these were
countries that were all
all the most most advanced in terms of
their struggle against communism and
then they had the most ambitious agenda
in terms of transforming themselves into
modern european nations who would
try to overthrow the overcome the legacy
of the last 40 years hungary the czech
republic and poland who's done the best
it depends what area of life uh the
hungarians for instance uh or have done
the best in terms of foreign investment
attracting foreign business but they
started even in the communist era to do
that they began to change their banking
system they tried to make make things
more attractive for for western western
businessmen
in
poland i think maybe there's the most
vibe individual initiative
you see people who started when i came
there three years ago who started by by
say selling
i uh food off from the back of their
truck
or bringing in bringing in food supplies
or consumer items from germany to
forming their own a store and then and
then then a company and then and then
going on from there
uh you see a great deal of enterprises
more chaotic maybe in poland than it is
in in czech republic or are in hungary
but it but it has that vitality to it uh
the checks have have been
had a little bit of a better start
because they did not have they were not
saddled with huge inflation a huge
foreign debt the way the polls were and
this was once a very czechoslovakian was
once a very powerful industrial country
in the beginning of this century and the
communists managed to run that down but
there was still more there uh and that
and the czechs have been
working hard towards towards beginning a
privatization process that's that's more
systematic maybe than the poles or the
hungarians so we really got to look at
various areas of life to decide give us
a broad overview on each country the
size and who's running it and what kind
of government they have tripoli poland
is the largest of these three countries
with a population of about 38 million
uh it it has had a until recently
governments which which stem from the
old solidarity movement most of the
people in power were people who either
were activists in solidarity or were
were people who supported the solidarity
movement now you've just had an election
in which because
the solidarity movement has fragmented
in so many so many different small
parties and because of a backlash
against some of the reforms
especially
on problems with unemployment the
growing gap between rich and poor people
the former communists have actually
rebounded and and have have gotten a
leading position and they are now trying
to negotiate a coalition government
where they will have a very important
role but these these former communists
are very different people than than say
the the the the former communists in
russia or who we see right now what's
like valencia doing now lek valencia is
president of poland he has been he was
elected in a free election in 1990
uh but what you see happening to him is
what what happened what has happened to
many people who were heroes of the 80s
and fighting the old system that once
they have to take responsibility for a
new system for the government it's a
much harder role
and so his popularity
is down
way down from what it was he's no longer
the kind of icon you had
you find that former dissidents have had
a hard time adjusting it's one thing
when you're fighting the system some of
the qualities you needed as a as a
dissident
to that you were very stubborn that you
were uncompromising that you would that
you would tend to see conspiracies
everywhere because there were
conspiracies everywhere don't
necessarily lend themselves to being a
good politician how many times have you
interviewed him
maybe about a half dozen times when was
the last time
last time was in
about six weeks ago have you noticed and
changed over the years
you noticed him changed in many ways
physically he's changed he's he's become
heavier uh more serious looking and this
was this was someone if you remember the
photos from the 1980s in 1980 when the
first strikes erupted he was a guy who
sort of vaulted over the fence of the
shipyard it's hard to quite imagine him
doing the same thing today
he's he's a person who's become i think
more worn down by the frustrations of
trying to function in in a democratic
society he's very impatient with the
rules and the constraints as president
he doesn't have big powers he's not like
an american president with huge it was
with very strong executive powers
it's more of a parliamentary system in
the european sense where there's a prime
minister who is who is the one whose
government is making the day-to-day
decisions he's often frustrated by that
uh he there's sometimes people accuse
him of wanting to be a dictator of
wanting to be to take over
and and and he's sometimes tempted i
think privately he will say if people
have said that he he to look at boris
yeltsin and say maybe that's the kind of
leader i'd like to be just sort of sweep
away all the rules but he hasn't and
that's a big difference there are rules
in poland that work rules of
parliamentary democracy that's a big
difference between the russian and the
polish situation you uh recount about
three jokes that they tell about like
valencia one of them was about the
the the water and the
gla empty glass along the nightstand
what what is that joke and what do they
tell them about well the the jokes are
can be fairly cruel the one you're
referring to is is it's it's about i
would like for unsa is a worker uh who a
shipyard electrician who's been vaulted
into these high positions and among some
some of uh some pola some some of the
polish intelligence
in particular there there can be a bit
of a condescending attitude towards him
and so you would have this kind of kind
of story like that the one about like
goes to sleep every night and he has two
glasses and by his bedside one and has
water and one is empty
why does he have these two glasses one
for when he's thirsty and one for when
he's not
these are kinds of jokes that you had
about communist leaders in the old days
who were
were maligned and were considered sort
of block heads uh
i think
it's a vast
underestimation of violence's abilities
to to to portray them in the same light
but it's a measure of kind of some of
the the bitterness that has emerged in
the old solidarity camp about the
differences between their political
differences the different personal
ambitions that there have been at play
here
that uh valessa is faulted by many of
the former solidarity people for
precipitating the splits among them very
shortly after they won
that produced a
big range of political parties that have
been very weak when they say if we had
stayed together we have been more
effective we would not never be in the
position of coming in second to the
former communists in these elections for
instance
and so that bitterness comes out
in these kinds of jokes which countries
uh border poland
well poland is of course bordered by by
germany it's one one very interesting
thing is that every country on its
border has changed in the last four
years
look
it was bordered on and by east germany
east germany no longer exists as part of
a greater germany
uh to the south the border was
czechoslovakia now you have the czech
republic and the slovak republic
and to the east you had the soviet union
now you have an independent lithuania an
independent belarus an independent
ukraine
so you can imagine it's it
everything has changed including the map
uh so so you
you when you look when when polls look
around themselves of course they were
aware
that the soviet union was not a monolith
and that there were these different
nationalities or the czechs and slovaks
had fundamental differences but it's
quite different being aware of that and
then to see
the sea this whole whole transformation
of your neighborhood some of your family
came from the what belarus from my
mother's family came from
came from near minsk and was in what is
the capital of belarus they were it was
a polish family that that had had a farm
near there
and my mother was actually born right
there on that farm
just about in 1917
right before the russian revolution and
they fled when the revolution came one
of the most
moving experiences i had in recent years
was i went back to min i went to minsk
in 1991 and i had a name the name of
this village where my mother was born
and her assumption was it probably been
wiped off the map there'd be no trace i
found it and i actually found
a woman who who had worked on my
uh who's whose mother and father had
worked on on my grandparents farm there
and who and she was she's she's in her
80s who actually remembered my mother
being born there and remember that
remembered what it was like in those
days how did you find that farm
i've i had the name of the village
and i had uh i knew how far it was from
supposed to be from minsk the name in
polish didn't quite agree with the name
names on the map in in in in russian
uh
but i started but i found the one which
seemed closest into in terms of in terms
of the distance that that my mother
remembered it was in terms of direction
and and closest in terms of name and i
went out there and there was this dylan
this terribly
decrepit state farm there
uh where where the sort of typical
kind of soviet scene of
of of farmers sitting in in in mud up to
their ankles and and and a few shacks
and there was a burned-out cottage and i
started asking did it for some of the
older people did anyone know where their
polish families here before i thought at
most i might get some vague confirmation
that once some polish families had lived
here but that's all
and then
a woman came up and said oh yes there
were polish families here and she was
she had been born in the uh early 1930s
and she said as a child i remember right
over there there was a church
where a woman
where where mrs bogdaszewska was buried
and bogda chess guys then my mother's
maiden name and this was her gray hair
and she was talking actually about her
grandmother my great-grandmother and
about what happened to this grave how it
was looted during the stalinist era when
when people driven by desperation and
hunger were actually looting graves
hoping they'd find some jewelry or
something
so and then and then this woman i was
just astounded and this woman
uh then told me that there is this older
woman who whose house had just burned
down and she's shown and this was the
house that i saw or where there was just
a sort of remains of of a cottage
had been moved to an apartment in the
village next door but that her family
had worked for for my mother's family
and i found her and spent an hour
talking to her
hearing her stories what language do you
use
i use i speak aside from polish i speak
russian
and uh
the this woman spoke in i'd say a
mixture of russian and and yellow
russian which is which is fairly close
to russian inter in term linguistically
uh i taped it because i was i for one
thing i was so
overwhelmed by what i was hearing i
didn't really i really wasn't wasn't
rely i wasn't confident i'd be able to
remember everything and so i so then i i
replayed the tape and and i could
decipher things that maybe i didn't
understand the first thing around the
first time around were you able to take
your kids or your wife with you on these
kind of trips
on this particular trip no no i i wasn't
but i've often when i have traveled
around around the region i've i've been
able to take
take uh especially my older older
children with me uh they've continued
some of the interest in this area and
and uh i've been able to take and and my
wife has traveled with me quite quite
frequently
got two other countries to talk about uh
to get the broad overview hungry
hungary as as i say is a country which
uh which has been going through a
transition longer than the others uh
it's a it is a country uh relatively
small in size a population of about 8
million
uh it's but it has a sense of proximity
to
austria where it used to be part of the
of course the austro-hungarian empire
was was was with there was a there was a
bondage there a sense of a middle
european or central european identity
and the hungarian communists throughout
the 80s and even earlier
tried to portray themselves as the
reasonable communists as the ones who
would
who would
allow
more maximum contact with the west
that would try to
to make kind of make a a some sort of
mixed economy work
and as a result hungarians were freer to
to to travel
and also politically less less repressed
than the others there was repression but
it was often in milder form one of the
one of the dissident writers once called
it a velvet prison
whereby you wouldn't you weren't
you were never you were in especially in
the 80s your dissidents were not
imprisoned they might not be allowed to
travel abroad they might lose and not be
able to publish or they might lose their
jobs but compared to the really
draconian
punishment which other eastern europeans
face they lived relatively well
and as a result the transformation in
poland in hungary took
it became a more evolutionary process
there was less of a one defining moment
when
when everything collapsed and something
started anew
and
this is both good and bad
it's made for a more stable situation
and a more reasonable
so it's a more predictable situation i
think it sometimes made people more
frustrated in that they didn't have the
catharsis of a moment of victory
and coming to terms with your past and
who you were then and who you are now is
sometimes more difficult
there are a hundred thousand jews in
hungary
that that's the approximate number
that's that's estimated in budapest it's
the only jewish community in eastern
europe that survived uh inter in fairly
in a fairly large number how many in
poland today it's
hard to know but
people talk about anywhere from five to
twenty thousand
how many in the czech republic
the very few were talking a few thousand
at most
joseph antol
joseph antal the prime minister of
hungary
is
compared to say lechva ansa or vatsav
havil
the czech president both of whom had
very glamorous
dissident past who brought down the
system antal is a former school teacher
historian a rather bland individual
but who's been
who was who was always against communism
but did not
lead any big crusade against it and he's
been again a very stabilizing influence
on the country
he's tried to
to be be very low key and moderate uh
due to
when when you think about it that for
instance on hungary southern border you
have the civil war in yugoslavia going
on he's tried to balance
the need to
to say could express concern about
ethnic hungarians living in in former
yugoslavia and other other
other countries in the region
with without
uh
awakening fears about hunger hungary's
alleged imperialist ambitions because
hungary once was a major power in this
region
so he's been he's been someone who's
who's held
he politically he's done rather well
but in in the last year or two his
popularity two has been slipping there's
a sense that that this kind of very
bland low-key policy is not enough
people are looking for other answers uh
as in
in hungary as as in poland for instance
or the uh or slovakia not so much the
czech republic you do have problems with
with unemployment in in a time when
state factories that were that were that
were unprofitable have to be closed down
or
or restructured
so he's he's beginning to feel
the the pressures of that and and in the
next elections next year he may not do
as well how many times have you been to
budapest or hungary well i've commuted
regularly between these places i've i've
it's
i really couldn't count the times but
it's been an awful lot uh it's this is
not a huge region uh in these three
countries uh and it's it's it's easy to
go back and forth especially you know
since the changes you fly or do you
drive or you take the train i usually
fly simply because i'm
you're on deadline so much of the time
and and you don't have much much time to
you can can sometimes i've taken the
train i rarely drive as i said you lose
time at borders it's a it's a long i
drive within the countries
uh but i find that uh on lengthier trips
it's just just given the demands of what
i'm doing it's it's even though it
sometimes would seem more pleasant to
drive i just just can't manage it what
are the countries that border hungary
well hungary to the south of course has
has yugoslavia that's the
the the the
the big neighbor who is who's extremely
trouble whose agony has also been felt
acutely by the hungarians they also
border and border on austria
and to the into to the north on slovakia
uh and in in it's it's it's and and then
of course there's there's romania in
each of those countries with the
exception of austria where there's not
so many so no there are not so many
hungarians
uh there there's a large hungarian
minority because hungary's borders used
to be much much bigger than this before
world war one
uh and then they as on they were on the
losing side along with austria and
germany in world war one uh their
borders were were
were
were shrunk
to a large extent and that left several
million
ethnic hungarians in other in in in
their in living in neighboring countries
in hungary based on all that when was
the first time you ever went there
i went there the first time i would say
let's see that was
early 1970s
what would you notice today if you had
to go back to the 70s different
well
you would have noticed budapest for
instance is
especially in its center a very western
city now uh and it's had already be
started to become that in the late 80s
but and by the 90s it's it's
it is
more it has more to it is more like
vienna in many ways than it would be to
to a city certainly in the former soviet
union anywhere
it's uh it has
uh the architecture of
the central european architecture of
of the last couple of centuries that's
very stately buildings even somewhat
polluted and and and and run down in
many cases
but the the kind of the business center
has been very very has been cleaned up
redone
uh and it's and it's a very attractive
place it's also it's a it's a city that
has a very is is a very beautiful city
with adenium flowing through it
uh and
and uh
the the the difference is that
as in poland it's come to life it's it's
you have you have a sense that it's it's
part of the world again
that's something you feel in so many
so many places in eastern europe in any
of these countries even in small towns
uh the small towns that say we're near
the border of germany and say in the
czech republic where
where before that was kind of the outer
reaches of the soviet empire and the
world stopped at there at the outlying
district of that town now is simply a
nice focal point for
for for uh europeans east and west and
that that's that's very much the kind of
even more so in budapest you feel that
it's a very cosmopolitan city these days
you go back to the earliest time when
you could see all this changing over
there and credit austria
with allowing the hungarians to come
through austria to get out
well what
you know it was
what i think a crucial moment in 1989
when all this was changing where there
were two major historical moments i'd
say that that were the cataclysm of this
change one was of course the solidarity
movement in poland and negotiate and and
forcing the government to negotiate a
partial
uh uh a partial giving up of its power
and and allowing opposition
uh opposition movements to to be
politically represented the second
crucial moment was hungary in 1989
september 1989
began
taking down literally taking down the
iron curtain
on the border between hungary and
austria there was the barbed wire all
the trappings of what we knew as the
iron curtain not maybe as many
barriers and so forth as as in some of
the other countries but it was there at
least symbolically the hungarians had
been allowed to travel to austria freely
since the for about 10 years by that
time
because as i had mentioned the former
communists had been trying to make a
point that they were freer and they were
they were more that this was a more
western eastern european country than
the others
but to demonstrate that they were
changing
they decided to take down symbolically
take down that barbed wire they actually
went there and took
wire clippers and started taking it down
at that point the east german people who
had been trying to get to west germany
were had always been allowed to travel
within eastern europe the so-called
communist countries
not to western europe and so they were
still able to flood travel to hungary
and they suddenly discovered the iron
curtains been taken down in hungary so
they would come to hungary
and then flee across to austria
and and that it it opened up a gaping
hole in that iron curtain and the east
german regime was faced with a prospect
either we just try to seal lock everyone
into our country
inc and not even allow them to go to
their eastern european neighbors
or
something's got to give and something
began to give they tried to get the
hungarians to close their borders again
the hungarians refused
because they knew this would be
seen by the west as a sign that they
aren't as
progressive and enlightened as the as
the hungarian communists wanted to
present themselves
and then this opened it all up when you
have a system which relies on keeping
people in
keeping people uh in in terror and
feeling that they have no options
once that begins to crack and very end
and just opens a wide wide open hole
like as you did in the hungarian case
then that had implications that that
helped that was the one event that
probably more than anything else brought
about the end of the berlin wall
story about czechoslovakia the split
who runs the [ __ ] the two countries how
big are they
czechoslovakia before the split was a
country with about 15 million
inhabitants
the czech republic
uh which is made up of the provinces of
bohemia and moravia has about two-thirds
of that about 10 million the slovaks
about 5 million
now
we in the west are used to thinking of
this as one country as czechoslovakia
but
in in throughout most of their history
until
after world war one when they were
became an independent state and were
unified the czechs and the slovaks had
very different histories
the checks were
under
austrian rule for in in recent history
the slovaks were under hungarian rule
the slovaks are more rural
catholic roman catholic people the
czechs returned to tend to be more
secular more industrialized more urban
and what happened was after
czechoslovakia became threw off
communist rule and during the communist
period
of course you had centralized control as
in any any any communist government and
any talk of czech slovak tensions was
was just just uh
basically
forbidden
the differences began to come out
and
and pretty soon within slovakia
you had various politicians in a bid
towards towards uh
winning elections playing on those
differences
and the current prime minister of
czechoslovakia of slovakia of vladimir
metro is someone who did precisely that
and sir and said to the slovaks we don't
have to be seen as second-rate checks
anymore let's be seen as slovaks and a
lot of it has had to do with this sense
of of we have to affirm our own identity
you tell a story about seeing mr uh the
the prime minister
mature
tell the story about stripping of the
hair
yes this was before mitchell became
prime minister
i uh went to see him he was it was clear
that he was going to become prime
minister uh and i went to his party
headquarters and mitcher is a former
boxer big guy
big hands sort of yeah sort of kind of
guy you expect to meet in in the local
bar and
and
and you wouldn't want to cross
too often
uh and
and again and the prime minister at the
time who was trying to preserve czech
slovak unity but also advanced or slovak
interest was a more very much an
intellectual a former dissident uh
a very mild-mannered guy and what struck
me as sort of the the capturing
encapsulating their differences was when
i went to see michiar
i i was going up a stairwell in this
building and i looked out and in the
courtyard there was a caretaker who who
had a hair
hung up and he was
stripping and he was he was gutting this
hair and and
and and the blood was sort of dripping
over the the garbage pails
and i went up to mitchell's office and
then
in the next office down down the hall i
saw there were about four or five dead
hairs it was the hunting season and some
of some of his his his colleagues had
gone out and shooting and uh this was
these were the trophies and
and this sort of fit his populist image
sort of the tough guy
out there even though he did he told me
he did not hunt himself but he conveyed
the image of the type of guy who
sort of a red meat politician in the in
literal sense of the term and it turns
out that in the new politics of of
eastern europe
that those are tactics that sometimes
work
geographically what's around slovakia
and the czech republic
well of course the slovaks
have the hungary which is the the
neighbor that they are most concerned
about they're also bordered onto the
east by the ukraine and to the north by
poland uh and then of course they have
their border with the czech republic are
they do they have anything with austria
at all no no they're far away though
from from bratislava oh no i'm sorry
sorry do this slow backs yes yes yes yes
of course they have there have yes
bratislava is very close to austria to
vienna you can drive there in half an
hour or so
so they they have but the neighbor that
they're most concerned about are the
hungarians they of course since the
hungarians dominated
slovakia for so long
uh they are very nervous about the
hungarians they have a minority the the
population of slovakia as i said is
about 5 million about 800 000
of that are ethnic hungarians and so
there's always the sense of of of
tension there that that there might
might become an issue although it has so
far been relatively muted uh but in the
news independent slovakia there have
been some tensions for instance metsyar
has has at times tried to take down
hungarian names of villages in villages
where where hungarians are the other are
the main
main group they've they usually have
both the name of the village in
hungarian and in slovak and he's wanted
to do away with some of that and that's
created some problems mr hubble
mr public mr havo the playwright the the
philosopher
who's who's one who's incredibly
creative writing
i i think and and ideas really had a
major impact on these changes and told
people that even if you are powerless as
in his famous essay he wrote in the
power of the powerless you have more
power than you think because this the
old system relies on your tacit complete
complicity and when you refuse to go
along with it
you begin to undermine that system
he's found it
both stimulating and frustrating
to become president uh you see him
yeah i i used to visit him in his
apartment when he was dissident now i
visited i visited him in in his office
as president
he's in this wonderful castle in prague
which is a presidential palace
uh but he and he genuinely feels
ambivalent sometimes about the trappings
of power although i think he likes likes
it ultimately uh as a playwright as an
intellectual as a his as a as a
philosopher
he's someone who's always a
very conscious of how
how
how
bizarre and surreal this is that he's
made this transformation
as a politician he sometimes has heart
had a hard time
making himself heard uh being as
effective as he'd like to be
he finds the rough and tumble of
politics difficult
and
and the daily politics is more dominated
by and by the prime minister of klaus
who's a very different kind of character
someone who's who's more of a
a a politician in the western sense of
of someone who who addresses simple
messages to the and tries to present a
programs which are very clear while a
philosopher and a writer like cavo tends
to speak in in much more
general terms and in much more
philosophical terms which which often
are harder to translate to your
electorate
a new york times reporter malcolm brown
was here a couple weeks ago with a book
and he said that prague is the most
beautiful city in the world
i think
it's hard to to find many cities that
compete uh of course whether it's prague
paris we're talking about that league
certainly why is it so beautiful um
it's a city which which has
well architecturally just wonderful
buildings
uh it's it's it's setting is beautiful
but it's primarily the architecture and
which which in the communist era much of
it had
had again been become run very run down
there was some renovation towards the
end
uh but sort of the greatness the of the
political atmosphere the fact that
somehow people heard about
czechoslovakia and they said oh this
hard-line communist state somehow didn't
register on people's
people's minds and minds that how what a
spectacular city this is
uh because there was a greatness and
that was not only physical in terms of
the buildings the lack of renovation
uh but also in terms of in terms of the
psyche of people there people fell
you felt that people were beaten down
there
now that that's changed people are
rediscovering prague and it is crammed
with tourists i mean it's wall-to-wall
tourists especially in the summer it's
become a favorite spot for instance for
young americans after after going
graduating from college to show up there
try to find a job teaching english or
are starting a business or
in the early days they were many tried
to be advisors to new government
ministries and
when when there was a real fascination
with america in all of these countries
and a sense that our americans will
explain to us how to make democracy work
how to make economy work
economies work and often they would you
know somebody who
very green from the us could could be
treated as a very serious advisor that's
changed as people become a little more
realistic
uh but there's it's still a very it has
the feel for for i think many of young
americans treated it a bit like sort of
paris
was treated by by the hemingway
generation in the 1920s as as a great
place to be
relatively cheap still uh and and just a
sense that you're living in a beautiful
place with us with a sense of history
that's and that's enormous in the oval
office right behind the president's desk
is a credenza that has a leather-bound
uh edition of writings of mr hobble
when you hear that
what does it mean why are people so
fascinated about his writing
because this is a man who i think by his
writings
managed to have a huge impact on history
and one can
talk about the impact people have in
terms of their ideas and the abstract
but in a very specific way in this case
he haavel used to love to talk about
what he called the radioactivity of
words i remember when i interviewed him
in i think
1986 he said
he talked to me about this at great
length and at first i was trying to
figure out what was he trying to say
and what what he was point was pretty
simple when you think about it but it
hadn't occurred to people so much that
why were the dissonance so important and
could have such an impact in these
societies when they were a relatively
small group of people especially in
czechoslovakia there were more of them
say in poland but in czechoslovakia the
dissidents were relatively small and
and and isolated group at first they
were constantly harassed they were
thrown in prison they lost their jobs
they were cut off from other people
but what he said was
that in a society
which where there are only lies where
everybody is officially saying
everything's wonderful economy is going
up everybody's happy
that if you can make yourself heard for
a moment with that truthful word it has
more impact often than say five million
voters voting a certain way in a western
democracy
it means suddenly other people realize
hey that person is saying what i've been
thinking all along but i have not been
able to express because of the political
system
and that puts a seed of descent there in
air and lots of people
and that begins to undermine the system
what's the green grocery store the green
grocer story
is about the kind of complicity that
everyone
had in the old communist system even if
you said i'm not political at all
i really don't want to be i don't want
to support this system but i'm not going
to go out of my way to to to jeopardize
myself by being against the system and
as an example the havoc took a green
grocer a person who has a little market
he said in order to live a quiet life
he would he would do everything that was
required of him if the communist party
said
go to a meeting and vote a certain way
he did that
if it said put up posters in your window
extolling the virtues of communism he
did that he said i'm not involved in
this it's just
just for show
and he would go and vote in the
so-called elections where there was
which were not elections at all there
was only one list of candidates and you
dropped the ballot in the box
but that whole show which some people
described as meaningless
haavo said was very important because it
it gave the impression of conformity and
as long as that impression could be
maintained then people who thought
otherwise even if they didn't if they
they really thought this was all
nonsense were afraid to speak out kind
of a guy is he to me
he's uh he's a kind of guy that you just
want to you would love to have more and
more time to talk to one of the
if there's a downside to this
transformation for me as a journalist is
that people like havo who in the old
days you could go and talk to for for
any amount of time almost because
they're then they were open they had
they were not allowed to do anything
officially you you could just ruminate
about
life the world what what's happening now
of course they're pretty occupied
they're president he's president of
their of his country you don't have time
for a lot of chit chat does he speak
english
howard speaks english it's not not
great english but it's adequate english
when he was a dissident
i would usually interview him in english
and he often said and bring my brother
along and to translate but then he
turned out he didn't need it as much as
president of course
when he wants to express himself very
carefully and realizes that his words
have yet another impact that as he says
any misplaced word
can can get him in trouble he he uses a
translator does he still live spend the
night in his apartment down at the river
and then go up to the castle in the
daytime he has he did that throughout
his uh first term as president
i just heard recently that he's moved up
to the castle uh i i've yet i haven't
been back to prague in the last a couple
of months to to find out if that's
definitely true but i heard that he's
now actually moved into the castle which
was which surprised me a little bit but
uh that's what i'd heard
you have a chapter called life without
censors and you uh talked with george
conrad and his wife judith cynthia
pronounced it
yeah
who are they george conrad is a very
well known hungarian writer
he's actually also now the head of the
international pen club
he's written many
novels and
about in the old days which were
considered somewhat dissident novels
they were not published officially they
were published in the west uh or
underground
uh and uh his his wife
is also been involved in the literary
scene and uh
and they're people i've known from that
those old days and i've kept in touch
with here's a quote from yudith um
with the end of communism there is the
end of intellectual
snobbism before it was important for
people to have good books on their
shelves now what's important is videos
and mtv
that's a feeling many intellectuals had
especially when the change first
happened because imagine so you had
these societies which had very little
access
to what
uh to what we call the pop culture uh
whether it's it's it's hollywood
blockbusters
or
bestsellers
thrillers
mtv
all of that and there was that sense
of all these people who had fought the
system to get rid of censorship to open
it up and some of these writers said
whoa what's happened here
uh suddenly
in the old days where everyone was it
was prestigious it was it was good
to to have a a ton a book of poetry or
to have read the latest political essay
to get the the latest nuance of what
what may have slipped by the censors
suddenly when you have a this tremendous
choice there was fear that the real
schlock culture will overwhelm
what were the the positive parts of of
of culture that survive during communism
precisely in opposition to that system
but i think what you've now happened
over time is that there's been a
balancing
you still have the best sellers you
still have mtv you have that but then
there have been new publishers which
find that who have found there is a
market for serious hungarian books or
polish books or checkbooks there are
there are people who are learning to
make movies in new ways because in the
old day for instance if you made a movie
that managed to get some little illusion
criticism of the old system in that
everyone went to see it well now that's
no big deal anymore you don't deal with
sensors so you've got to do one that's
entertaining here's uh who you dedicate
this book to tell us about these three
people
they're my parents uh marie and zigmund
i dedicated
the book to them
they are alive they live here in the
washington area uh and
of course my own sense of who i am and
my own
my own identification with
with e with with poland comes
through my upbringing which which they
which they provided me with
and then the other person there is my
youngest son alexander who's five years
old i dedicated the book also to him
perhaps because i did one previous book
and i in which i dedicated to my my wife
and and other children at the time
alexander was not around i didn't want
him to feel left out
where do you go where did you go to
school
uh i went uh i in growing up i went to
school to
high schools in various places in
egypt
korea france when my father was in the
first foreign service and then i came
back to college in in the united states
i went to amherst college in
massachusetts what did you study i
studied history uh
mostly modern european history and then
as in that senior year where i spent a
semester in poland i i then did my
i used that as material for uh for a
lengthy thesis on the changes of in in
in poland in 1968 during that period
when when the warsaw pact invaded
czechoslovakia
when when a polish student movement was
put down by the polish authorities and
uh
so it's it's quite a
a
a few an incredible feeling to have gone
from that to be describing
the birth of these these totally new
societies where did you go to work right
out of amherst
i taught high school for three years in
the boston area in weyland massachusetts
and after that i
tried to break into journalism uh
vlogging my college clips whatever i
could and i was lucky enough to get
a tryout at newsweek which was
in those days they they had a trial
program whereby
they took relatively any very
inexperienced people like myself and for
a period of anywhere from two weeks to
six months they kept you on tryout and
at the end of the any week they could
say
sorry kid it hasn't worked out
it made for a very stressful period but
it meant you had a shot at that's that's
something that that could develop into a
good job and
somehow i survived you took a breather
at what point to do the carnegie
endowment for peace this was after i'd
been abroad as a correspondent for 10
years in various places in hong kong
moscow rome and bond
and then i came in 1988 i came to
washington
to to go to the carnegie endowment to
give me a chance which was a wonderful
opportunity to
to do uh
maybe say some some more analytical
writing uh to write for and and speaking
and and to look into
into some subjects in more depth and in
a different way than than when you're
faced with
the weekly deadlines how much longer do
you expect to be in warsaw
uh at the moment i'm in no hurry to
leave it continues to be a fascinating
part of the world
and i'm also
from warsaw i also i also now go back to
the to to moscow from time to time
i was
for many years not able to go there
because in 1982 i was expelled from
moscow as you remember
but now i'm able to go back and forth
and so i've been able to also
follow that story
so i find there's it's it's it's hard to
imagine right now a more exciting part
of the world to be in so if newsweek
wants me there i'm happy to be there if
it was time for you to make a choice on
where you'd live for the rest of your
life what would you pick
that's a real hard one and i better
discuss it with my wife first but
i think
at some point we will certainly come
back to the united states and
where and depends obviously on what i
would be doing and
what the job possibilities would be uh
but we don't have we've we've we've
bounced around so much in our lives that
we don't while we consider washington
our home because we we lived here for
two years uh uh and that's the most
recent experience in the united states
it's it's hard for us to know at this
point where we will end up what is your
favorite city forget that you might have
to live there someday but what would you
pick is your favorite city in the world
um
it depends for different things i mean
prague has to rank real high
in my in cities i like i like paris and
awful lot and i like hong kong very much
this is what the book looks like it's
called the birth of freedom and our
guest has been andrew nagorski we thank
you for joining us thank you
[Music]
join us next week for book notes when
our guest will be charles me former
editor of american heritage magazine and
former editor-in-chief of horizon
magazine
he'll join us to discuss his recent book
titled
playing god
seven fateful moments when great men
meant to change the world
that's book notes next sunday night at 8
and 11 p.m eastern time here on c-span
[Music]
coming next on c-span will take you to
london for this week's prime minister's
questions in the british house of
commons
[Music]
join us tomorrow morning here on c-span